know how big Tommy Bahamas they would
swallow you whole they would flush your
soul do you know how suicidal I am
I'm the kind of guy that'll bolt my own
business just to prove a point
[Music]
I know you're a fan of Raising Canes I
love raising kids no they came up out of
nowhere even though you never eat the
best part the bread oh because I always
give it to my girl she loves it so you
give her the best part you give it to me
too bro I do give it to you I was
talking about you my girl
everything he does is so awesome and
nice he's a [ __ ] guy yeah [ __ ]
such a zany wild gray guy he's the new
enemy I hate that [ __ ] don't you make us
all look bad
this guy sent the message
everything's wild yeah bro it's a wild
day so uh um Raising Cane's chicken
fingers sues Indiana Shopping Center
after being told it can't sell chicken
fingers
already kids told the shopping center
they're not allowed no no no raising
canes through the shopping center Sue's
the shopping center because the shopping
center tells them you can't sell chicken
fingers oh so they think they have
exclusivity in the region they do have
that so why would they let them [ __ ]
open in their shop I'll tell you the
shadiness right now okay tell me the
detail so for those of you not familiar
with Raising Canes it is a literally
chicken fingers
basically exclusive thing it says
chicken fingers in the [ __ ] title
okay they're every [ __ ] word
everywhere they're killing it a
restaurant famously known for
exclusively selling chicken fingers
assuming a Northwest Indiana Shopping
Center after being told eight months and
over a million dollars in construction
later that it would be prohibited from
selling chicken fingers due to a
long-standing undisclosed deal with
McDonald's McDonald's they don't even
they're not even in the town they got
chicken fingers McDonald's doesn't have
chicken fingers they used to have the
selects remember the selects yeah they
don't have that anymore oh that's right
oh and then they took it off the menu a
lawsuit followed by Raising Cane's in a
federal court in Texas alleges that
Crossings of Hobart and property owners
Schottenstein Property Group tricked the
popular chicken finger chain into
signing a 15-year lease that would
equate to more than two million dollars
in rent while never disclosing that
McDonald's held the exclusive rights to
sell chicken at the shopping center
located next to South Lake Michigan
Sioux commercial real estate is amazing
you can lock someone in for 15 years
like that and go oops well you kind of
want you kind of want more years because
then um what commercial real estate does
too is let's say you have shorter years
and you become tremendously successful
then like let's say if it's less than a
five-year lease then they go oh by the
way your rent just won yeah they just
hike it up because they know you've
spent so much money on building your
[ __ ] already yeah that if it's like
Helix you know they're like all right
well [ __ ] it I'm doing really well here
and they're like okay well it's double
the rent now
there's no rent control like residents
have
for them it's like whatever wow yeah and
um they're supposed to disclose it
because like even in my um shopping
center they told us that there's a
coffee exclusivity that they have with
one of the tenants so we're like oh we
have coffee products and they're like it
has to be mixed with tea it can't be
pure coffee like all that stuff so I'm
like I get it if they have that contract
they have that contract so they're
supposed to tell you beforehand though
they can't say yeah come on into our
building but what's stupid is that they
sh this place should want Raising Canes
to open because then you have a tenant
that pays rent but not only that a lot
of shopping centers they collect a
percentage on your profit or your gross
so like if the if the business is open
they might even make more money
with your business open so I don't get
why they would do that maybe they don't
want to get sued by McDonald's that's a
no [ __ ] that but that's also stupid to
not disclose it so short yes
short-sighted yeah that's a weird that's
a weird and raising canes is part of its
push into Indiana plan to build a double
drive through restaurant on the site of
affordable TGI Fridays can anyone does
anyone know how they track it double
drive-throughs so like double yeah you
go through the drive-through on one
angle and then there's a drive to the
other angle and there's people getting
some people are way too polite and they
hold up and they let [ __ ] three
people go how do they know I think uh
when they're filling out the order
they'll write uh for example it'll be
like a gray Odyssey yeah or be like blue
Mini Cooper yeah really well they'll
have people in the car lines like
Chick-fil-A Chick-fil-A just ask your
name right yeah yeah they have people
like sometimes sometimes when I like
look at like the POS or something like
that it'll say something like uh like
Asian white hat yeah you know what I
mean so they the the the internally they
understand how to like work or they have
the little eyes the little Asian eyes
yeah they just draw us perfect perfectly
like on the Starbucks cups they do a
Chinese hat with the Asian eyes oh
that's good what yeah no we did a whole
JK it was about like a couple of times
they would just do like little squinty
eyes on the Starbucks cup instead of
their name
wow despite knowing that anyway
quote quote it's both despite knowing
that the entire business model of
Raising Cane's chicken fingers is
premised on the sale of chicken fingers
defended specifically did not disclose
the issue before the lease was executed
so it basically like you said why would
you not disclose it it's basically super
super either dumb or Shady trying to
lock somebody into something and then
maybe expecting them not to like Sue or
something it sounds more dumb because
at the like let's say they do this right
and they pull it off the the
consequences like this is way far
greater than how much they're gonna make
oh and the lawsuit claims that not only
did the defendant specifically tell
Raising Canes that there were no
exclusivity rights that would affect the
restaurant oh that's even worse but that
the defendants even tried to sell
Raising Cane's the exclusive rights to
sell d-bone chicken at the shopping
center all while knowing McDonald's had
already been sold that right
that's [ __ ] up okay they try to double
dip in that Polynesian sauce dude this
is the claim of the lawsuit yeah
quote incredibly defendants did not tell
Raising Canes it would be unable to sell
its chicken fingers at the shopping
center until nearly eight months after
watching Raising Cane's spend nearly a
year of time and over a million dollars
to develop its new restaurant
that's pretty fun that's super [ __ ]
did she gets too hard in general real
estate commercial real estate landlords
and stuff like that that whole game is
uh it's a game it's a game my one of my
um most wealthiest friends he's got like
over 100 Mil and like just
like net worth and [ __ ] he started
um in the in that game like he was he
was working entry level at a commercial
real estate company and he's worked his
way up and like the level of like the
[ __ ] that they do I'm just like those
numbers I can't even understand yeah
because it's like they're they own
multiple shopping plazas all that [ __ ]
and I'm like yeah damn you [ __ ]
Lowe's pay rent to you like that's crazy
you know like like [ __ ] you get Old
Navy and they pay rent damn I never
heard of that like Target pays your rent
they're long contracts yeah that's crazy
because I'm just out here thinking about
like like a thousand bucks a month but
then you got to deal with Lowe's calling
saying the toilet's clogged oh that's
the worst exactly like you're a hardware
star I'm clogging yourself
Lowe's is like our [ __ ] neighbors are
like running over the roof or something
here's some extra anecdotes according to
the lawsuit a little over a week after
Raising Canes began construction on the
site of a former TGI Fridays The
Crossings of Hobart sent a letter to
McDonald's seeking a waiver of their
exclusive rights in order for the
shopping mall to secure Elise with
Chipotle McDonald's reportedly declined
the request the lawsuit states that in
McDonald's letter the golden arch fast
food chain also reminded the property
owners that the proposed Raising Cane's
chicken fingers would be a violation of
the terms of the exclusive shipping
layers yeah so they try to do it and
order the property owner to quote
immediately cease any such proposal to
sell chicken and quote do you think the
guy who owned the TGI Fridays there
before I was like I'm never selling
chicken again in my whole [ __ ] life
that I am a chicken selling chicken
broke me broke my brain
like they they ran them out yeah I did
he got [ __ ] over yeah poor guy he's
like [ __ ] it we're never selling chicken
here again what what do we got steaks
we'll sell steaks I wonder how gangster
McDonald's contracts are I mean also the
lawyers they probably know they don't
have to Cave into anything yeah but just
the idea of like McDonald's isn't
necessarily like
no known for chicken of course like we
all like know them to have chicken they
have so many different tactics to block
prosperity of competitors yeah even if
it's not even the same [ __ ] they're just
like no we want people to just go to
McDonald's yeah it's crazy yeah because
it's maybe not not necessarily like well
we don't because they don't even have
those strips anymore I don't see it at
this no they just don't maybe for them
it's like yeah Raising Canes is popular
we don't want you to eat your lunch
there everyone's gonna choose that over
McDonald's definitely you know what they
[ __ ] up is I don't really see the
[ __ ] crew anymore I don't see
McDonald's I don't see Grimace yeah
that's true the hamburger it means the
crew we need the squad that's where they
lost I love the idea of all of those
characters rushing into a raising canes
and just trashing the place
around here
the hamburger is in there he's like I
don't know what to see
[Laughter]
I've never had this problem before
having an existential crisis it's like
I'm useless he's like what do I do I
need to call my mom
I don't know what to steal I don't want
to give more information because that's
way better than anything yeah I think
we're good I want to know everyone's in
the grants you want to know yeah is
there yeah of course you're interested
in that I'm a nerd when it is dude this
is like
despite McDonald's strong stance the
defendant said nothing to Raising Cane's
the lawsuit said instead defense stood
on the sidelines as Raising Canes
continue to incur over a million dollars
in development costs lawsuit goes on to
say that the crossings of Hobart once
more tried to get McDonald's to waive
the exclusive chicken rights days later
but McDonald's again strongly urged the
property owners to have Raising Cane's
seats construction according to the
lawsuit defendants didn't come clean
about the exclusive rights until March
22 2022. six weeks after turning the
property over to Raising Cane's so I
think this is
um McDonald's Raising Cane's having to
deal with the landlord not each other
because that exclusive is with the
landlord so if the Raising Cane's opens
up they just open up yeah and the
landlord's probably like no I'm sure I
could talk to McDonald's and figure it
out I think they were trying to like
alleviate it along the way it's like no
no we gotta try and get the Chipotle
okay [ __ ] that didn't work uh Raising
Cane's already started construction uh
let me try again you know what I mean
what would you do if you opened up your
your June B finally and then Tommy
Bahama across the way was like we have
the exclusive to matcha
Tommy bye bye
we're already open bro
what would you do Tommy but bye bye
you know how big Tommy Bahamas they
would swallow you whole they would flush
your soul do you know how suicidal I am
I'm the kind of guy that'll bolt my own
business just to prove a point dude
Tommy Bahama will have so many boat dads
coming through your front door it's the
guy with the boat shoes you could be
hitting them with machine guns and
there's still more Boat Boat dads coming
through yeah it's like [ __ ] World War
Z dude yeah dude that would be the
weirdest matcha exclusive like they sell
shirts if I were in Raising Cane's shoes
and like I was already almost a mill in
I would be like I gotta open sorry guys
there's just no way I have to open I'll
deal with the consequences later because
what are you gonna do is just say oh you
won't let me well okay because it's one
choices you guarantee a 800 000 loss the
other one is uh you open you make some
money lawsuits come and maybe at least
you have income and you can drag it out
you can pay it out in a bigger level
that's what galaxy Samsung did with
against the iPhone you gotta yeah we're
ripping off all your patents we're gonna
build a whole other lane [ __ ] won't see
you in court and they did that and they
got sued for a billion dollars but it
was so profitable for themselves and
they save their whole business
because you want to be like oh well I
guess we can't and then you [ __ ]
guaranteed lose a million rather be in a
position with options than you just you
can pay your lawyers yep I'm gonna steal
people's [ __ ] yeah
honestly let's do our own movie Let's do
our own TV
we'll do black cheese first thing that
comes to mine let's do it hey guys hey
you know what we'll sell our June beats
for 40 off [ __ ] what are you gonna do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign